foreign
[Music]
Bart Rose I am a assistant professor of
surgery and chief of HPV surgery at the
University of Alabama in Birmingham and
I will be speaking about population
disparities in neuroendocrine tumors
I have some funding through the NIH and
nanettes on this topic
for those of you unfamiliar
neuroendocrine tumors are derived from
ectodermal multi-potent stem cells they
can produce a Barren physiology due to
hormones secretion but about 40 to 60
percent of these tumors will not secrete
any measurable hormone about half of
patients will present with metastasis
liver being most common side and the
natural history of these tumors is
variable some behaviorally aggressively
and others are very indolent they can be
associated with certain genetic syndrome
such as immune Von hippo Lindo ts1 I'm
sorry TSL and neurofibromatosis one
the most common sites vary on region uh
the in the U.S the most common site is
the rectum followed by the small
intestine and the pancreas being the
third most common side
these tumors as mentioned before can be
functional meaning that they secrete a
hormone and this is more common with
pancreas tumors the depending on the
type of hormone secreted they can have
variable symptoms if they for example
produce gastrin patients will often
present with recurrent ulcers
small bowel neuroendocrumors and
Pulmonary neuroendocrine tumors can
produce a syndrome called carcinoid
syndrome which is associated with facial
facial flushing diarrhea bronchospasm
and heart valve disease this is usually
a sign of menostemic diseases most of
these are processed in the liver 90 of
these patients will have an elevated
metabolite of serotonin in their urine
and as mentioned before more commonly
associated with the lung and the mid gut
these functional tumors have varying
malignant potential most of them have
the ability to metastasize with the
exception of insulinomas has a very low
risk of metastasis
non-functional tumors which are about
half of these tumors typically will
present because the mass effect of the
tumor itself leading to abdominal pain
weight loss from gastric Outlet
obstruction or jaundice from biliary
obstruction
usually noted on a CT scan or MRI but
occasionally an endoscopic ultrasound
biotemical biochemical tests can reveal
hormone secretion
but this is challenging if there's no
clinical syndrome
you can use alternatively a chromogram
and a level
although this is variable and can be
increased or leading to false positives
with any number of medications and
sometimes diet
a gallium-68 dototate scan for B can be
helpful for localization
the incidence of neuroendocrine tumors
has been rising there's been a over
six-fold increase in neuroendocrine
tumors that have been diagnosed since
1973. there's about seven per hundred
thousand persons will be diagnosed with
the neuronic consumer in the United
States this year this increase has been
across all sites and stages
interestingly this occurs at about the
same time we see an increase in CT scan
use
in suggesting that what we're seeing
here is actually an increase in
incidental tumors questioning whether or
not they have any clinical relevance
foreign
Nets have been increasing mostly in the
low-grade and localized neuroendocrine
tumor variety again suggesting that
we're just catching early potentially
benign neuroendocrine tumors however
there has been a slight but steady
increase in the rest of them over time
there are different types of
neuroendocrine tumors
um we typically will grade these
according to level differentiation and
then on proliferation is measured by
either ki-67 or mitosis
very
low-grade tumors they're usually are
well differentiated with low
proliferative indices but as we increase
the
um
level differentiation to become poorly
differentiated we then refer to these
tumors as neuroendocrine carcinomas
rather than neuroendocrine tumors and
these are treated much more similarly to
other solid tumors and are true to a
systemic chemotherapy rather than
hormonal therapy or surgery
in 2007 there was this re-categorization
to include this new category of a
well-differentiated but still high
proliferative index
neuroendocrine tumor called a grade 3
neuroendocrine tumor
the clinical treatment for this
classification is yet to be
fully hashed out
it is clear though that these grade
three neuroendocrumors do behave
differently
compared to their neuroendocrine
carcinoma Counterpoint or counterparts
who have a very poor
median overall survival and those with a
grade 2 well-differentiated
neuroendocrine tumors which have an
improved overall survival with these
this new classification somewhere in
between
now for a
localized non-metastatic neuroendocrine
tumor surgery is
often considered Curative we can see
here when looking at patients who
undergo surgery versus any type of
resection of a pancreatic neuroendocrine
tumor there's a significant Improvement
in survival however the question is
could this be due to a selection bias
and then we're selecting patients who
have more favorable tumor biology and
not operating on those who aren't
this next study tried to answer that
question in 2009 where they looked at
patients who were resected patients who
were recommended resection so
theoretically were healthy enough to
have a resection but then ultimately
opted to not have a surgery and those
whose surgery was not recommended and we
can see here again a clear Improvement
in survival in those patients who had
resections compared to those who were
recommended resection but did not
undergo it again suggesting that surgery
is potentially Curative and is a
Mainstay of treatment for localized
disease
now there are known racial disparities
across many different cancer types and
this is true also in neuronic tumors
we're given as a relatively rare cancer
this hasn't been studied to the extent
as it has in in some other malignancies
such as breast prostate and colorectal
we do know that black patients have a 11
higher age-adjusted death grade for all
cancers compared to White patients
and this is thought to be resulting from
a Confluence of both socioeconomic
Health System environmental and biologic
factors
little is known in neuroendocrumors
this first study looked at the Seer data
set from 1974 to 2015. this included 53
000 patients about 15 percent were black
and what they found was that rural
uninsured unmarried men with Advanced
disease were more likely to have poor
disease specific survival black patients
were found to have worse overall
survival but not the specific survival
as noted here with the hazards ratio of
1.16
for none Hispanic black or versus
non-hispanic white
I remember the problem with the study
was that it was heterogeneous and
included both pulmonary and
gastrointestinal pancreatic
neuroendocrine tumors
this additional study looked at the Seer
data set again from 2004 to 2015 this
time and excluded peanuts so this was
really focused just on gastrointestinal
neuroendocrine tubers this included a
little over 26 000 patients about 20
percent were black and fifteen percent
were Hispanic and they found that white
patients were more likely to have
surgery but black patients had better
overall survival into these specific
survival
again this was a heterogeneous
neurointer Continuum population
including rectal small bowel and gastric
the first study to really look at
overall survival is specific to peanuts
I looked at the ncdb from 2004 to 2015
it's Incorporated about 16 000 patients
of which 12 were black and nine percent
were Hispanic and they found that there
was no difference in overall Survival by
race instead they found the income
education and insurance type was
associated with
poor overall survival
this would suggest socioeconomic
influence
however looking another study looking
again at the Seer data set from 2004 and
2013 this time focused specifically on
pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors
had a smaller number of about 3 800
patients but 13 were black but this time
found that black patients were more
likely to have distant disease
29 versus 23 in white patients were less
likely to be offered surgery
and had a worse disease-free survival
for local disease
and as a and close to a worse
disease-specific survival however the
p-value is just barely positive
but this would suggest potentially an
access issue
patients were not being offered surgery
as often for something that was
potentially curable for local disease
when patients did have a resection their
survival was similar
the U.S net study group which was a
Consortium of a number of multi or high
volume institutions focused on
neuroendoconsumer care
decided to look at their own granular
data set incorporating patients from
2000 to 2016 which there were nearly
1200 patients all of which would had
resections for low-grade
well-differentiated neuronic consumers
about 14 of these patients were black
within this data set they found that
black patients had a better five-year
recurrence free survival
but we're more likely to be lymph node
positive
47 versus 36 percent
interestingly we find that white
patients and black patients uh if they
were lymph node Negative black patients
did significantly better
however when lymph nodes were positive
recurrence-free survival were similar
this would suggest that black patients
had earlier lymphoma metastasis however
if they received resection before
lymphomaastasis occurred they would have
improved survival
this led to our institutional study
looking at our own data set of 151
patients who underwent resection for low
grade
well differentiated or under consumers
between 2010-2019
this
cohort had about 25 black patients what
we found was that black patients had
larger tumors on average but did not
find a difference in disease-specific
Survival by race
patients with greater than two
centimeter tumors had worse disease-free
survival
however this was not
uh when we looked at this by uh race we
didn't find a significant difference in
recurrence free survival based on tumor
size
this would suggest that well our black
patients had larger tumors it didn't
have the same impact on Survival as it
did on our white patients
began to suggest there may be a biologic
influence on
outcomes both on the U.S net study group
which suggested a difference in
lymphomaastasis and on our data set this
suggested a difference in size was not
translating to a difference in outcomes
now however this study was relatively
underpowered
and all this really plays into trying to
figure out who should be offered
resection
so we we think that resection is
potentially Curative and definitely has
an impact on survival
currently our recommendations and
guidelines
will recommend that patients who are
symptomatic with either functional
tumors or non-functional tumors that are
large in causing symptoms such as pain
or obstruction should go under undergo
resection
however there's some controversy about
what to do with asymptomatic patients
who have non-functional tumors
current guidelines recommend observation
for tumors less than one centimeter
resection for tumors greater than two
centimeters and for clinicians to use
clinical judgment for tumors that are
sized between one and two centimeters
the size that we use is approximate
proxy for likelihood of metastatic
disease
this is based on a number of studies
which in 2001 this meta-analysis reform
that showed that size was
correlated with risk of lymphoma
metastasis
we know that when tumors in the pancreas
pancreatic neuronic consumers get larger
than two centimeters there's up to a 40
percent risk of lymphomaastasis at time
of resection well
sub two centimeter tumors have somewhere
between a five to maybe 10 percent risk
of lymphoma
suggesting that observation may be
adequate
however all these data sets are derived
from primarily European and white
patients and not and had not been
validated
based on patient race
this led to our recent paper from our
group in the Journal of American College
of Surgeons where we investigated
whether or not current size based
guidelines in Black patients with p-nets
were accurately being predicting a risk
of lymphoma metastasis
to perform the retrospective analysis of
the U.S net study group combined with
our institutional data this Incorporated
patients with resected tumors from 1998
to 2019 all these patients had
non-functional well-differentiated
neuroendocrine tumors that were not
associated with an inherited genetic
syndrome
this was then validated against the
larger National Cancer database or ncdb
data set
we excluded patients who had known
metastatic disease who had resections
that were done for non-curative intent
in all high-grade or poorly
differentiated neuronic tumors
these are the demographics of both the
study set and the validation data set
and to summarize this essentially the
findings that we found were that um
patients
black patients were more likely to be
younger female and have lymph node
positive disease than their white
counterparts
the size characteristics at Baseline
were similar between the two patient
groups
we looked at the risk of lymphomaastasis
based on
size of the primary tumor
we found that first for greater than
three centimeter tumors there is no
statistical difference in the U.S net
study group
or in the ncdb data set
risk of lymphoma metastasis was
somewhere close to 40 percent which is
in line with the previously published
meta-analysis
when we looked at tumors between two to
three centimeters
we again found no difference in the
usnet seti group or in the validation
set in the ncdb
however when we looked at sub two
centimeter tumors now these are these
are tumors that we would recommend
observation because they theoretically
have a very low risk of lymphoma
metastasis we found a stark difference
first in the used U.S net study group
only five percent of our white patients
had lymphoma passes time or resection
which is in line with published data but
up to 23 percent of black patients had a
lymph node that was positive with a sub
two centimeter tumor
in the ncdb data set this difference was
a little bit less Stark but was still
significantly positive with a two times
risk of lymphoma metastasis
for black patients compared to White
when we looked at that sub two
centimeter
subset even closer we found that the
risk of a sub one centimeter tumor was
nearly zero and why patients for risk of
lymph node metastasis but up to 25
percent in the U.S net study group
and in the one to two centimeter range
it was seven percent versus 23 percent
in the ncdb
this was a little bit less Stark but
remained significant
again having nearly two-fold change in
risk of lymphoma metastasis in Black
patients compared to White
and the study was somewhat limited as it
is a retrospective review and introduces
bias by Nature individual individual
patients may be represented in both data
sets as all the U.S net City Group
Consortium sites also contribute to the
ncdb and the ncdb does not report on
tumor grade but it does report on
differentiation so therefore we should
be able to eliminate poorly
differentiated tumors which are
generally high grade
from that study we concluded that
recommendations for surveillance of two
centimeter pancreatic neuronic tumors
are based on a low rate of lymphoma
metastasis seen in primarily
predominantly white patient population
that the incidence aluminum metastasis
is in Black patients in sub two
centimeter tumors is clinically relevant
and concerning and the current
guidelines may not be universally
applicable in a more aggressive approach
towards resection in Black patients with
small peanuts may be warranted
based on our clinical data it would
suggest that there is underlying
differential biology driving some of
these disparate findings between our two
racial groups
the question goes to what do we know
about the genomics
of pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors
well we know that the U.S study pop the
U.S population is about 13 black
but when we look at analysis of racial
and ethnic representation in all cancer
genomics
we see that only about two percent of
sequence genomes of tumors are from
black patients
this led us to ask the question what is
known in pancreatic neuroendocrumors
specifically
to answer this question
We performed a
meta-analysis and review using natural
language processing
we started with 3300 records from PubMed
and in base
and after excluding articles for
duplication
not meeting inclusion criteria we're not
reporting the race or ethnicity of the
patient subjects we were left with 13
articles to be included for a
quantitative analysis of representation
his work was primarily done by a
graduate student Brendan herring
when we looked at these 13 articles we
found that nine articles
included
analysis of tumor DNA
141 patients were included in that three
articles focused on the transcriptome
including 279 patients and only one
article looked at methylation status
that included 40 patients we looked at
the genomic
that these genomic studies and broke
them down by race we found that only 26
patients were included in all 1938
sequence patients
representing about 1.3 percent of the
total
as there were no published data sets
looking at the differential expression
between black and white patients we look
for ways to answer this question
we found the aacr project Genie dataset
and utilized this as an attempt to begin
to understand were there differential
Expressions between racial groups of
common genes
the aacr genie data set includes a
number of panels of commonly mutated
cancer genes
when we looked at in that Gene data set
and looked specifically for mutations
that were likely to lead to a
functional loss of protein such as
indels and truncations
we found that 337 white patients had
peanuts for analysis and 23 black
patients when we look for differentially
expressed genes between the two data
sets
we found
um a number of differentially expressed
genes
a interesting one was the Emmy in one
gene which has been shown previously to
be the most mutated Gene in pancreatic
neuronic tumors in about 40 percent of
tumors which is in line what we've what
we saw in our white patients
interestingly our black patients had
nearly a half of that of their tumors
were mutated with him in one at 17
percent
we found additional genes that were
enriched within our black patient
population that were not within our
White
we then asked the questions whether or
not this mutation in the immune 1 and
the other commonly mutated genes of Dax
and aatrax
translated to the protein level
and well we found that there was no
statistical difference in the
staining for Dax and aatrax on a tissue
microarray of patients
and our institution with the resected
peanuts this included 40 white patients
and 13 black patients
we did find a statistically different
number of patients with me and one
mutations leading to a loss of protein
with 11 of our white patients and none
of our black patients having mutations
enemy and one leading to a loss of
function
because perhaps the most variation
between racial groups occurs at the
epigenetic level and such differences in
epigenetics have been shown to influence
racial disparities in multiple cancer
types we took particular interest in the
epigenetic regulatory networks that were
mutated
the conducted clustering and Gene
ontology analysis to figure out if and
how these genes were related to one
another
what we found were these genes formed a
nice interaction network with one
another
clustering brought in other genes were
significantly associated with our query
genes to augment the network and help
determine the pathways that were
affected k-means clustering put these
genes into three distinct functional
interaction clusters depicted by colors
here
mdm2 degrades p53 myod1 is involved in
muscle cell differentiation but in
cancer plays a role in suppressing
migration and invasion
cert 1 inhibits apoptosis and senescence
and supports the viability proliferation
and invasion of pancreatic cancer cells
smad2 is a tumor suppressor
smark C1 is another core subunit of the
sweet Swift complex bath and lastly KDM
6A is a histone methylase
looking at the pathways that these genes
affect through their interaction Network
we pulled out four major categories in
red is endocrine function and pancreatic
beta cell differentiation which you'd
expect with pancreatic neuroendocrine
tumor yellow is chromatin Remodeling and
nucleosome regulation green is
proliferative signaling and purple is
p53 and DNA damage response
using this information we wanted to see
if we could characterize some specific
functional convergences in the genes
that we identified in original analysis
because we are including the
immunohistochemistry and mutational data
in our review of racial groups and get
net sequencing we started to build a
rudimentary model of them
interestingly came to TD is necessary
for Minion to exert its function as a
histone methyl transferase then
methylates lysine 4 on the H3 tail
promoting transcription of a host of
factors including cdk Inhibitors p21 and
p18 among other anti-proliferative genes
smart CB2 and km2d and ep300 form a
complex with one another that increases
lysine 27 acetylation and enhancer
elements throughout the genome
regulating a complex Gene Network
EP 300 and sweet Swiff complex also
interact with one another to facilitate
the enhancer function of the endocrine
transcription Factor PDX1 which is key
in pancreatic beta cell differentiation
and maintenance of differentiate State
differentiation states in the adult
pancreas importantly loss of PDX
function has been shown to confer poor
prognosis in peanuts with the enhancer
signatures clearly influencing peanut
biology
finally
immun1 smart B one and kmt 2D all
inhibit the nuclear translocation and
activation of active beta-catenin
thereby inhibiting the prolifer the
proproliferative signals activated
through the wind pathway
these data indicate that perhaps what
black patients have fewer mutations in
immun1 the genes that are mutated and
instead seem to share some important
functional roles with it hence the
aberrations May simply lie at these
different nodes in the in imian's
functional pathway and ultimately result
in similar Downstream effects in these
cancers while conferring some
differences in the tumor biology that
we're seeing at the clinical level
namely differences in the rate of lymph
node metastasis
in summary
significant differences exist in the
clinical outcomes between black and
white patients with peanuts black
patients are more likely to have early
lymph node metastasis the immune1 gene
is commonly mutated in white patients
but apparently less so in Black patients
other epigenetic Regulators are more
commonly mutated into black patients so
may have the same Downstream effect
I'd like to acknowledge my collaborators
herb Chen shisher mathel and Ryan fields
and Clayton Yates as well as the lab
members who perform the majority of this
work Brendan Herring candidate MD PhD
Rachel Gunter postdoc my lab raging
pywol former postdoc and Amanda Fang a
medical student who's now in her
residency
thank you